once your ml model has been trained and
is ready to make predictions you'll need
to be able to serve it cue flow serving
or KF serving is a powerful open source
tool you can use to serve your models
with the scale and performance of
kubernetes let's look at how KF serving
gives you an easy-to-use interface so
you can serve models in production to
see the documentation on KF serving
check out the link below kubernetes
brings powerful features to training and
serving your ml models but it can be
tricky to handle the configuration of
servers auto scaling networking and
health checks of kubernetes clusters to
run your models in production KF serving
aims to hide this complexity to bring
you a simple pluggable and complete
story for our production ml serving this
includes everything from prediction to
pre processing post processing and
explain ability it gives you standard
interfaces for common ml frameworks like
tensorflow XG boost scikit-learn and pi
torch giving you a consistent experience
for models of all kinds its interface is
a y mo file typically checked into a git
repository simply point your
specification respect to a serialized
model file and cloud storage and you get
a live model at an HTTP endpoint on top
of that KF serving lets you leverage
cutting-edge production serving features
like using GPUs auto scaling scaling to
0 and canary rollouts to your ml
deployments KF serving is installed by
default as part of a queue flow
installation but you can also install it
as a standalone using a quick script
check out the link below to learn how
behind the scenes KF serving is built
using the extensibility of kubernetes
and the layers that sit on top of it SDO
is a service mesh layer that takes care
of the load balancing security and
monitoring of the micro services that
make up a kubernetes cluster it enables
SCAF serving to handle traffic routing
and ingress to your deployed model K
native is a layer that lets you deploy
and manage service workloads on
kubernetes it enables KF serving to
handle networking and canary rollouts so
you can safely make changes to your
endpoint without dropping any traffic
and it even enables you to auto scale
GPUs and TV use for ML scientists this
means adding something to the KF serving
resource is as simple as using the KF
serving interface that's provided for
class for example when you want to tweak
min/max replicas or perform a canary
test for Emma ops engineers this means
applying policies under the hood becomes
much more manageable with the layered
kubernetes architecture like when you
want to apply security policies failure
recovery metrics and monitoring let's
walk through an example interface while
you can create a short llamo file to
quickly serve your model and get an end
point there are many ways you can
customize things like authentication and
canary rollouts here the min and Max
specs are a way to control your
provisioning of back-end pods to make
sure that you don't drop requests and
you can meet demand without overspending
behind the scenes Kay native handles
routing and queuing of traffic you can
also specify resource requests like
selecting gpus and thanks to K natives
concurrency based autoscaler you can
effectively scale CPUs or GPUs by
default KF serving sets target
concurrency to 1 so if you load the
service with 5 concurrent requests the
autoscaler will scale up to 5 pods and
back down to 1 when requests die down
for most ml scientists one of the
biggest challenges is how to deploy
models in production using Canaria
rollouts you want to be able to easily
test and update your data models to
production without impacting users while
traffic's leading to backends is a
challenge KF serving lets you slowly
increment traffic from an old model to
an experimental model in this example
we're rolling out a new version of an
iris model as we slowly increment
traffic percentage to our b2 model we
can be confident that canary isn't going
to disrupt our users eventually we'll
move 100% of traffic to our v2 model
then delete the original deployment
allowing you to completely manage the
lifecycle of data models in production
when it comes to processing data ml
frameworks don't give you a place to
execute code that process requests KF
serving includes hooks so you can
provide your own container
implementations to do pre and post
processing you just need to add the hook
in your KF serving interface specify a
container image spec for your processing
handler and KF serving automatically
wires it up the hook called a
transformer can help you process
requests like if you want to translate a
user ID into a set of new features about
the user these new features can then be
fed into another hook called an
explainer that can perturb the features
and send prediction requests to them
perturbing features to see its effect on
a models output is one way of explaining
or shedding light on your models
finally the predictor can do predictions
on those requests post process them in
the transformer and send the transform
request back to you together these hooks
give you a simple way to serve an
end-to-end ml model with explain ability
at your fingertips KF serving gives you
out-of-the-box standardized model
serving across frameworks is built for
production inferencing with features
like Canarian auto scaling explain
ability and a clean interface making it
easy for you to review models and change
config on the fly
[Music]